being generic but he really is always
authentically cat which i appreciate and
this special i
i will
i will say half of it
um
i was on
i was on board for half of it like
gung-ho the first half yes this is
authentically cat he's making incredible
points
and he what i love about his comedy is
that
he can talk about complex issues and
topics
but make it very grounded make it very
just approachable
yes yeah yeah yeah um yeah like so
analytically so i counted the last
special okay
and there was 290 so right around like
300 300 laughs and it was a 57 minute
special so it's about five and a half
laps a minute technically right about
five to five and a half laps a minute
his speed and style
gave way to where a lot of the things
a lot of ways that he
was getting
laughs i recognize is very different
than other people
he got laughs a lot on just like facial
expressions and physicality
where he didn't say anything and just
got laughed just by a certain look or by
a certain thing that he did on stage
which i thought was super impressive i
mean we kind of know that cat williams
you know
some of the stuff that he did in the
early days
the physical stuff was some of the most
hilarious things that you remember like
yeah
uh about his kid having a dd
um
was just the funniest thing his way his
kid ran he was like i just want to run
i don't know if you remember that which
special that was but it was just
hilarious just the physicality of this
kid running running like running from
this side and you see cat running from
this side
of the stage yeah yeah
and it was just good so like i really
like enjoy that part the other piece
like that i really found unique about
his approach
he repeats his points a lot throughout
higher special
like there was a couple things that he
said he was like um
[Music]
what was it
live versus truth
lie versus truth
lie versus truth
[Music]
repeat it like over and over again and
just like there was just lots of things
even like when he's talking about the
chicken wing shortage which is a great
joke oh my dude
that's why the second half let me down
because he was i was like oh he's going
all in here he's talking about
good job on drugs
10 minutes that chicken wing joke was
about a 10 minute joke it was so funny
it was so funny chicken shortage of
chicken wings but not thought like
there's just
these obvious things like and not
chickens that likes
these things yeah he said taco bell is
selling chicken wings he's like it's in
revelations people talk about how the
world is ending like
just incredible yeah the lie versus the
truth yeah
lotsy
but they don't tell you the truth yeah
but just like there was just a repeat of
like
those kinds of things of like
so i feel like he definitely stuck on
the theme of like world war three of
just like this war of what to believe
what not to believe lie versus the truth
um
like
good uh what was it was something hold
on
did your camera just move oh okay yeah
yeah yeah
um
oh yeah just when you start because he
also brought it back to like god made
chicken
to be
the most like
the greatest animal because in every
culture everybody eats chicken
and just like how he brought that back
was just so so funny so i felt like he
really kept it to the truth until
the closer like it was like where did
this topic come from
and that was the only thing that took me
off of it was just like this closer i
get it but it felt very club-like and it
was just talking about like
eating
women and i was like come on eating
women even you edited it like it had it
had me clutching my pearls
how far he went and it wasn't just the
closing bit i mean the last like 20
minutes it was it was a good it was a
good solid at least 10 minutes
but even leading up to it like he was
talking about things like it basically
went from like all this very like
really amazing observations with very
unique points of view i mean the war on
drugs not happening anymore because
black people don't make the drugs like
black people don't make fentanyl
you know it's like like he was making
all these incredible points and
observations and then it just went
south it just went straight to like
literally literally literally south
he eased into with adam and eve's stuff
and then it just kept going south from
there and the fruit and then it just
the cream and i
i finished it
because i love cat and we were doing
this show today but like i was like
dang man i wonder why
not
just do an entire special
like the first half or really the first
40 minutes i mean
i don't know for sure yeah i think it
was for me
but that it i and honestly i don't ever
remember cat going like
dirty like that
that was a that felt like a first for me
like in watching cat williams all these
years has he ever gone sort of just like
that graphic
for that long yeah
you know i'm saying like i just don't
i don't
see that joke and think
cat williams
and i think that's what kind of took me
out of it i was like man you take are
you talking about world war three you're
talking about what's happening in
society you've got all these poignant
points
and now you're gonna end it on a i mean
he ended it on a big [ __ ] joke yeah
that's really what it was yeah yeah like
what are we doing
i know so that would
kind of took me out of it
if if he found a way to tie it in like
do do the sex jokes and make it some
sort of analogy to a bigger picture
about society or politics or something
like he did with all these other topics
you know but he literally just went
from all these incredible observations
i'm like wow that's an amazing point and
it's hilarious to then it's just like
sex jokes that you could hear
at any given comedy show you know and i
don't
i don't
like a very
it felt like something like you said
that you didn't think
a prof not i don't want to say a
professional but like yeah a long time
professional
it felt like so something that someone
found like earlier on in their career
versus something like a veteran would be
doing it felt like two different sets
like it really and i love cat and i'm
not throwing shade at all you do
whatever you want to do he sold out a
big theater in vegas to film a netflix
special clearly cat's doing what cat
wants to do and it's working for him but
as a comedian
that loves cat williams it's like ah
come on bruh push us across the finish
line i mean he really just
it it was just so graphic
here's the thing i think i was okay with
it
until
it just kept going like i think like
okay i get it that's funny like kind of
thing
but like it was it was a elongated bit
like it was a very long almost like oh
no i need to fill time like
yes that's what it felt like it felt
like i was like you had your cat
williams dude you got
you're you're hilarious i i mean and
it's not that it wasn't funny right it
just took me out of the mode based on
everything else that i just saw with the
special
yeah yeah yeah i totally agree yeah and
that's what tavis said yeah the end of
the special cut abruptly like he ran out
of time
um
yeah
yeah yeah i don't know so i don't
it did kind of abruptly end i don't know
like i'd love to ask him about it
um
just to see like
what what what what happened there
yeah
yeah yeah i mean
it wasn't the greatest closer that i've
seen from cat because all his closers
have been like
very poignant but
also you know what it was
that closer
didn't close up the entire topic that he
usually talks about and kat is actually
very good at like bringing things back
and i didn't see that with this special
like in all the specials i remember like
he made a big hoopla at the end to bring
back the point that he was making in the
beginning so like just something like
just
i don't even say it was just call backs
but just something to like wrap it up
and that didn't feel like a wrap up it
just felt like
here's a here's a there's a joke that's
it next joke
yeah
read it on a truck stop bathroom wall
uh and then here you go
but that being said the special he still
has a lot of hilarious bits in there
still super physical you know he's like
hanging on to the mic stand at one point
like
still his timing
like that's something
i think when we talk about earthquake
special and just the amount of laughs
per minute and now he just he does not
take the foot off the gas or as they say
he keep he keep his foot on day neck
as we say in this game
but what i did enjoy about cats like
performance and his delivery is how
paced it is and he really is just like
building tension
with his pauses and he's in no hurry and
everything's on time
and everything has a purpose i really
enjoyed the performance aspect not only
the physicality but just the confidence
and the pacing of it was really good as
well yeah and i really liked his crowd
work in this one as well like i i just
loved
how he kept going to the crowd just like
for like quick bits like oh the white
people are nervous right
like and he just kept doing it but it
was so organic it was never
demeaning it was never like it didn't
feel lazy at all it felt like you were
just like that's what i liked about the
whole special was just like it felt
interactive in such a way like let me
tell you all about something that i
think is a little effed up and the dj
yeah he had a few dj queues in there too
yeah yeah and the oh yes exactly those
dj kids were on
point and part of that he makes amazing
points about like joe bi like there's
just so many things about the war on
drugs and like politics and then it just
goes
it just goes i don't get it man
i don't get it i don't know why i would
love
i think part of it is just like
that's maybe it's just that's who cat is
maybe what's the yeah
yeah then someone who's like every once
in a while i got something dirty i want
to say i mean it's kind of like
chappelle does that too he'll say all
these profound things and then like a
silly joke that's dirty just for the
sake of comedy you know so but he kept
going
he kept going
[Laughter]
but
we're gonna start for those of y'all um
for those of y'all that have been
watching us in eclipse lawn care said
he's uh he's watching while mowing he's
listening while mowing so we appreciate
that
um we are gonna start grading comedy
specials
on the earthquake laughter scale
um
so
for this
cat williams
world war three netflix special
yes
what do you give
what do you give
on a scale of one to five earthquakes
earthquakes i give this
a four earthquakes
a full reason i give it i give it a four
earthquakes because
everything about the special was great
until the last like 15 minutes of that
bit
like
if i took the entire special those last
like because it was an hour special it
was like 57 minutes it was an hour
the last like 15 minutes i could have
done without so like the rest of it for
me was pretty spectacular
and i got and i understood like
even in the bit
was as dirty as it was i still counted
the laughs
and like there was a lot of laughs in it
so like even though it wasn't like my
speed
it's hard to say that
it wasn't a good performance because the
audience was eating that thing up
like just
all right well
i give it a four yoshi gives it four
earthquakes out of five
um this is so cool
i'm gonna give it and i'd be interested
to know what people think in the the
comments what they would give it but i'm
gonna give it
i'm giving it three out of five here now
i i i love cat
he's absolutely hilarious he's been one
of my favorites since i saw pimp and
pimping and since i've been in comedy
he's been kind of
a north star for me in terms of just
performance and the writing that he does
but in this one i mean
the jokes how he ended it it just it
just he made all these amazing points
and then it just got super dirty in the
last quarter of it
and that really took me out of it
because it was such a left turn
and
i get it i get the dj's stuff
that it's cool and it's fun and it's
playful and that's what you want to do
but that kind of took me out of it i'm
just a purist you know of like when it's
multimedia
and i but i enjoy
i enjoy special effects like
the the special effects when uh
when who was it kevin hart had the
toilet
or the toilet yeah
like i enjoy because it feels
three-dimensional it feels like we're
not only talking but there's music
there's like
art like even like and that felt like it
had a purpose but for cats the dj he
could have done without the dj stuff and
um
i don't know for that
and just how it
it just kind of faded out for me
okay that's that's fair that's fair yeah
so i it feels like hot breath it's a
three and a half stars a three and a
half
earthquake we're gonna give we're gonna
give pat williams
three and a half out of five earthquakes
for his new comedy special
this is so cool
chris o'connor said amazing graphics
nice work
thank you so much so if we did three and
a half i don't know how to do i was
trying to combine them
so three and a half earthquakes out of
five for mr cat williams